IMAGES AND VIDEOS THAT WE'RE
GETTING FROM UKRAINE.
IT'S DREADFUL, AND NOW WE'RE
GETTING WORD THAT PUTIN MAY SEND
IN, OR APPARENTLY IS GOING TO
SEND IN 1,000 MERCENARIES INTO
UKRAINE.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL US?
THESE ARE 19-YEAR-OLD RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS WHO IN SOME CASES MIGHT
NOT BE ABLE TO SHOOT STRAIGHT OR
EVEN UNDERSTAND WHY THEY'RE
THERE.
>> THESE ARE OLDER, SEASONED
HARD-BITTEN PEOPLE, AND -- I
THINK THAT THE MESSAGE HERE IS,
A CERTAINLY AMOUNT OF
DESPERATION ON PUTIN'S PART TO
HAVE TO DO THIS AT THIS POINT.
I THINK THAT APPARENTLY THEY
THOUGHT, THE RUSSIANS THOUGHT,
THEY WOULD WALTZ INTO UKRAINE
AND THE UKRAINIANS WOULD JUST
ROLL OVER AND CAPITULATE.
WHICH OBVIOUSLY HASN'T BEEN THE
CASE.
WHEN HE STARTS BRINGING IN
MERCENARIES, ONE OF THE THINGS I
WORRY ABOUT IS LOCAL USE OF
CHEMICAL WEAPONS AGAINST THE
CIVILIAN POPULACE.
OF COURSE, PUTIN'S GOOD BUDDY
ASSAD DID THAT IN SYRIA, WHICH
ACQUIESCED IN.
THIS IS CONCERNING.
>> WHAT OPTIONS DOES THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY HAVE
LEFT AT THIS POINT?
IF THE U.S., IF NATO ARE SAYING
AT THIS POINT A NO-FLY ZONE IS
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN, AND THE
SANCTIONS HAVE BEEN ESSENTIALLY
MAXED OUT AT THIS POINT.
PERHAPS THERE'S MORE THAT CAN BE
DONE.
BANNING RUSSIAN OIL AND SO ON.
>> THERE IS, THE REMAINING THING
SANCTIONED, WORSE THAN ENERGY,
OF COURSE, WILL HAVE BLOWBACK
AFFECT ON US AND THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
>> PUTIN SAYING, THAT WOULD BE A
DECLARATION OF WAR.
THAT IT ALWAYS IS A DECLARATION
OF WAR.
>> TO ME, WE, US, U.S., 20
MEMBERS OF NATO ARE ALREADY
COMPLICIT BECAUSE OF THE WEAPONS
PROVIDED, NOTABLY STINGERS AND
JAVELINS RESULTING IN A LOT OF
RUSSIAN DEATHS AND I LOVE THE
CLIP OF THE HELICOPTER GOING
DOWN.
SO -- AND WE'VE BEEN SANCTIONING
HIM IN ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S GREAT.
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER SINCE 2014.
SO THIS IS -- YOU HAVE TO PAY
ATTENTION TO WHAT HE SAYS,
OBVIOUSLY.
HE TOLD HIS COMMUNITY, I KNOW,
CERTAINLY -- IT'S ALMOST LIKE
AFTER THE FACT DECLARING WHAT
IS, HAS LONG EXISTED,
PARTICULARLY WITH A PROVISION OF
SECURITY SYSTEMS, WEAPONS, TO
THE UKRAINIANS AND HOW GREAT DO
YOU THINK PRESH HEAR TO BE ON
PUTIN INTERNATIONALLY?
I MEAN, COULD IT BE ESCALATED?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW, WE SEE --
>> CHINA NOT --
>> OBVIOUSLY IN SHANGHAI WERE TO
WEIGH IN AND NOT HELP THE
RUSSIANS GET AROUND SANCTIONS,
OR PROVIDE AN ALTERNATIVE SOURCE
OF FUNDING IN THE FACE OF THE
SANCTIONS.
IF CHINA WERE TO DO THAT, THAT
WOULD HAVE IMPACT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE, WHAT
OTHER ARROWS WE HAVE IN OUR
QUIVER SHORT OF DOING SOMETHING
LIKE A NO-FLY ZONE.
ALTHOUGH AT THIS POINT, A
NO-ARTILLERY ZONE WOULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN A NO-FLY ZONE.
>> RIGHT.
AND BE I GUESS, WHAT OTHER KINDS
OF WEAPONRY COULD BE SEND IN?
I KNOW COLONEL ALEXANDER VINDMAN
TALKED ABOUT, WHY DON'T WE SEND
IN DRONES?
ARE THERE OTHER TYPES OF WEAPONS
TO BE FUNNELED IN TO HELP
UKRAINIANS EVEN THINGS OUT A BIT
MORE?
>> I DON'T KNOW THE STATE OF
PLAY THERE.
WHETHER COVERTLY OR OTHERWISE
THAT THAT SORT OF THING ISN'T
BEING PROVIDED EITHER DIRECTLY
OR INDIRECTLY.
WE HAVE A LOT OF RECONNAISSANCE
AND SURVEILLANCE AIRCRAFT FLYING
IN THE AREA.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY'RE LOOKING INTO
UKRAINE.
SO I'M SURE WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN.
I CERTAINLY WOULD BE IF I WERE
STILL THE DNI TO MAKE THEY'RE
UKRAINIANS GET ALL THE
INFORMATION THEY COULD POSSIBLY
GET, PARTICULARLY IF IT HELPS
THEM KILL RUSSIAN SRUSSIANS.
>> IF THIS DRAGS ON WEEK AFTER
WEEK AND SEE THE HUMANITARIAN
TOLL, A TOTAL NIGHTMARE BEYOND
WHERE WE ARE NOW, THE WHITE
HOUSE SAYS, NO BOOTS ON THE
GROUND.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO WAR WITH
RUSSIA AND SO ON.
I ASK THIS OF A GUEST EARLIER,
RUBIN -- RUBEN GALLEGO TALKED
ABOUT IT EARLIER.
YOU CAN'T SHOOT ROCKETS AT
NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS AND
INDISCRIMINATELY WIPE PEOPLE
OUT?
>> I THINK POWERFUL IMAGES THAT
ARE PORTRAYED OF THE WANTON
BRUTALITY HAVE HAVE IMPACT.
THAT IS GOING TO CAUSE, SURE
ALREADY HAS, PRESSURE ON U.S.
AND NATO TO DO SOMETHING EMPTY
BEYOND WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT
NOW.
NOT TO MINIMIZE IT.
IT'S QUITE SUBSTANTIAL.
BUT THIS IS ON STEROIDS.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT SITUATION,
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT, BUT I
REALLY WONDER WHAT THE IMPACT IS
GOING TO BE OF THIS CONTINUED --
IF THIS CONTINUED AND I PREDICT
INCREASING BRUTALITY OF THE
RUSSIANS AGAINST A UKRAINIAN,